hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast better knowledge better care
precision medicine for any cancer any
essay on your platform presented by rate
Samara senior global product manager NGS
kyochon and dan Richards vice president
biomedical informatics kyochon I am
Alexis Krause of laberd's and I will be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by laberd's and
sponsored by kaijin for more information
about our sponsor please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license
located on the far left your screen and
type your questions into the drop down
box that appears on the screen our
speakers will respond to your questions
via email
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credit please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit please
join me in welcoming dr. Samara and dr.
Richards I will now turn the
presentation over to them
Thank You Alexis on my name is rod
somato what I would like to go through
today is some background on our chiastic
tmb panel a brief background on tmb
analysis and what we have done to to
enable such analysis using NGS platforms
so just as an as an outline for for
today's webinar I will go through some
basic principles of immuno Oncology I'll
go through you know what tmb is and why
we are looking at tmb and then the
solution that that kyon has put together
for tmb analysis which is the kiya ck-mb
panel
as a disclaimer um any chiastic targeted
DNA panel is intended for molecular
biology applications and this also
includes the chi seek PMD panel and
these products are not intended for the
diagnosis prevention or treatment of a
disease
so just to give some brief background on
immuno oncology in to touch upon some of
the hallmarks of cancer that we see this
has been extensively described in the
literature over the past maybe 10 to 15
years we know that as normal cells
progressively evolved to enter new
plastic ones they acquire a succession
of 10 different hallmark capabilities
one of these hallmark capabilities is
avoiding immune destruction and immune
oncology approaches seek to modulate the
immune system to promote anti-tumor
activity and counteract this hallmark we
know cancer cells divides certain
methods to avoid immune destruction by
by the immune system and what the immune
Oncology approaches are trying to do is
to modulate this this approach however
for immune oncology approaches to work
they generally incorporate an
understanding of the mechanisms of tumor
escape within the tumor microenvironment
it cancer cells do not live in a vacuum
they live in an environment which
contains several other cells as shown in
here so we know that the tumor
microenvironment is a living organism it
consists of many different cell types
mainly tumor cells and tumor
infiltrating lymphocytes tills do have
the capability to kill tumor cells they
get primed in the lymphocytes in lymph
nodes they they infiltrate the tumor
they recognize tumor cells and become
and remain activated however what we
also know is that the tme cells in the
tumor microenvironment are in constant
interactions and sculpt each other's
activities
tumor cells have divided these
mechanisms as i mentioned before to
avoid immune destruction and I will go
into some of these mechanisms in a
little bit but we know that cd8 T cells
recognize targets by binding to the T
cell receptor in it by by binding the T
cell receptor to antigens associated
with MHC class 1 molecules this binding
actually leads to the activation of T
cells however the immune system in order
to keep itself incident in check has
devised these these mechanisms to keep
it also in an inactive fashion through
the some of these PD 1 receptors or
other receptors that exist on T cells
this is a normal normal function of the
immune system
however what we know is that the is that
cancer cells have exploited this
mechanism to avoid immune destruction so
what what tumor cells have devices
they've divided this expression of PDL 1
which is the ligand for PD 1 that is
expressed on T cells and PDL 1 The
Binding of PDL 1 to PDF to PD one
actually keeps the the T cells in an
inactive function so cancer cells have
exploited this axis of PDL 1 and TD 1 as
well as other axes that I will go into a
little bit but they have exploited this
this kind of interaction to keep the T
cells within the immune system in an
inactive state and try to avoid
destruction by T cells so the PD 1 PDL 1
binding inhibits inhibitors prevent the
binding of pd-1 to PDL 1 so researchers
have devised ways by which to keep the
PDL 1 pd 1 access sort of in check and
by using these kinds of inhibitors that
prevent the binding of PDL 1 to pd 1
now the T cell remains in an active
state and can attack tumor cells this is
the whole idea behind immunotherapy as
an immuno Oncology is to again break
these kinds of breaks that have been put
onto T cells by by cancer cells by The
Binding of PDL 1 to pd 1 or other types
of immune track Indian checkpoints and
these immune checkpoints some of them
are shown or shown over here the ones
that have been exploited by
immunotherapies is the PDL 1 PT 1 access
lots of PD @tp d1 or anti PDL 1
antibodies have been devised to break
this kind of sort of interaction between
pd 1 and PDL 1 the ctla-4 and b7 one to
access has also been exploited for
immunotherapies but what you see in red
these are the breaks that that the new
system and and the cancer cells actually
used to dampen the england responses we
all know that there are multiple signals
that are required in order to keep the
immune system active but in in certain
instances these inhibitory functions of
the immune system get a get actually
activated and all of these mechanisms
will lead to D to the inactive
of amuse of a new system and that's what
cancer cells have exploited
immunotherapies have several
immunotherapies have been have been
approved by by the FDA and other
regulatory bodies some of them are are
listed here but you could see that they
mainly target the td1 PDL one axis as
well as the ctla4 b7 one two axis they
have been approved for different types
of diseases and cancers mainly for
melanoma and non-small-cell lung cancer
and bladder cancer and this is important
because as you will see in a little bit
these are the types of cancers that
express a lot of mutations in and tumor
antigens so this is something to keep in
mind because the the efficacy of these
types of therapies is going to be
dependent on the types of mutations and
the number of mutations that are
expressed by these but by the different
tumors but the immuno oncology is now
because of immunotherapy is enamine
oncology research in you know oncology
is now a pillar of cancer therapies
traditionally we've seen chemotherapy
radiotherapy and surgery of the three
main pillars of cancer but now because
of all of the advances in immune
oncology research in the you know
therapies or that fourth pillar and
immunotherapy has come in many different
shapes and forms from checkpoint
inhibitors these are d this is like this
is the modality that I just described
whereby you could use an antibody to
break that interaction between
checkpoint inhibitors between
checkpoints and and their ligands and
but but also we see immunotherapies in
the form of cancer vaccines as well as
car t-cells but what I'm going to focus
on today are mainly the checkpoint
inhibitors however when the idea of
exploiting the immune system or
modulating the immune system to to treat
cancer is it is a very is very
attractive because we could see long
lasting effects however we know that not
every every type of tumor is going to to
be responsive to to immunotherapies and
this is actually summarized here you
could see that for different types of
tumors that you see on the left hand
side you see their their response rates
four different types of of
immunotherapies whether it is an anti
pd-1 antibody and an TPD a1 antibody and
what have you so the one of the biggest
questions that that you know researchers
are trying to find answers for is well
why do we see certain cancers responding
to these kinds of reagents but but other
cancers are not in one of the one of the
logical sort of elements to look at is
PDL one expression because if you are
breaking the you know the interaction
between PD 1 and PDL 1 illogical element
to look at is the expression of PDL 1
and when you look at the expression of
PDL 1 in these types of tumors and try
to correlate it to the responses that
you see of these types of tumors to the
different antibodies you you don't
really see a sort of a one-to-one kind
of correlation where if the tumor is
expressing PDL 1 it will respond to
these kinds of antibodies in one of the
sort of the the the cases that everyone
is looking at nowadays is colorectal
cancer we know that colorectal cancer or
53% of different you know colorectal
cancer samples that that researchers
have looked at expressed PDL one but
when you look at the responses of of
colorectal cancer to anti pd-1 and anti
PDL one antibodies that you don't really
see a good response you don't you don't
see a response period so the question
now becomes is why when we see you know
high levels of PDL one expression that
the tumor is not responding and this is
what I'm trying to get to with the with
tmd analysis tmb is becoming one of
those biomarkers that you could look at
in addition to PDL one expression to try
to figure out why a specific tumor is
responding or not responding to to any
other therapies so again the question is
why do we not see any responses if the
tumor is expressing PDL one and the
answer is you don't you cannot really
look at just one biomarker in order to
to understand you know how immuno
oncology therapies work you probably
need an approach that interrogate s--
several different elements and
incorporate them into sort of one type
of analysis so when we look at and
approach for immuno oncology I've
borrowed this this kind of approach from
from a paper that was published in
science that looked at something called
immuno grams and it's B it's basically
an approach that looks at many different
elements within the immune system in
order to figure out and understand why
certain cancers respond to these kinds
of therapies and why others don't and
you see that there are several elements
from lymphocyte counts to tumour
mutational burden and microsatellite
instability analysis to gene expression
analysis to tumor metabolism microbial
profiles and what have you and we know
that next-gen sequencing is an ideal
technology for an immuno oncology omics
approach because it can be used to
interrogate several of these elements we
know we could use an NGS approach to
look at the immune repertoire for
instance we know we could use an NGS
approach to look at gene expression
levels as well as MHC levels and new
antigens or microbial profiles or tumor
mutational burden and MSI levels so what
I will be focusing on today is the tumor
mutational burden aspect of this
immunity of this in unigram what does
mutation to TM be what does it mean and
how can we examine tmb and why would we
examine TMB and how occasion has put
together what kind of solution the guy
should put together for tmd analysis but
before I get into the solution I'd like
to spend a couple of minutes going over
the the concept of TM B and in TM B is
just basically it is the mutational load
in tumors right it's it's basically out
of the thousand or out of the million
bases that have been sequenced how many
mutations do I see in this sample and
the reason why I want always like to to
go back to this to this figure that was
published in in a paper back in 2017 is
that because you can see that the number
of mutations per million basis sequence
the number of mutations are highest in
melanoma and lung cancer and bladder and
remember these are the three types of
cancers that actually respond very
favorably to two to immunotherapies and
so it seems that you know the higher the
number of mutations you have the more
responsive that tumor is going to be to
such therapy
but and the idea of tmb is to basically
just analyze the number of mutations
that you see in a sample that is that
that's what what tumor mutational burden
analysis is all about so the solution
that Kaizen has put together for TMD
analysis is a is a DNA panel it's called
the chi seek TM be DNA panel and the
workflow of such a panel is is shown
over here starting with as little as 10
nano grams of DNA that DNA goes into
several steps in order to to to
construct enriched libraries that's the
first of which is fragmentation it's a
single enzymatic reaction that fragments
your DNA input into smaller pieces once
the the DNA has been been fragmented and
dramatically library construction is
that second step with library
construction you are constructing
libraries and assigning unique molecular
indices I will go into what um eyes are
all about and how they can be helpful
with with the with the analysis but that
second step is you are my assignment and
library construction with um eyes you
are labeling the original DNA molecules
so that with your analysis pipelines you
can come back and ask the question am i
analyzing the data based on original DNA
molecules or am i analyzing the data
based on duplicates and triplicates and
what have you that you know within your
reads the third step is target
enrichment by single primer extension
and I will go into what single primer
extension is also all about but
basically you enrich for all of your
targets within an individual pool of
primers and once you are your targets
have been in which the last step is
library amplification you amplify your
library and you complete the
multiplexing in order to multiplex up to
384 samples per sequencing run once the
library amplification is finished your
libraries all ready to be to be
quantified and sequenced so the the
solution that we have put together is a
sample to insight solution in the sense
it is in the sense that it covers both
the chemistry part of a very
construction as well as the analysis
pipelines there are two boxes that are
required from from a chemistry
perspective you have your panel box that
contains proprietary pcr chemistry's to
enrich even gc-rich
optimize RNA to cDNA conversion
chemistry fewer if you're using any of
our RNA solutions as well as primers
that are based on single primer
extension approaches for enhanced
uniformity I mentioned RNA because these
workflows are not just compatible with
DNA you can actually use the same
workflow for with RNA as a starting
material to call fusions or gene
expression levels the second box that is
required is the index box these are the
molecularly bar-coded library adapters
that incorporate unique molecular
indices so the combination of a panel
and an index the the index is the is
sequence or specific element the panel
box is platform agnostic in the sense
that you could use the same chemistry
regardless of the platform the
sequencing platform that you are using
these two kits cover the library
preparation site and enrichment and then
on the analysis side we've put together
a barcode aware that analysis pipelines
that will analyze data based on unique
molecular indices and we also have
interpretation solutions and then we'll
be speaking about some of these
solutions in his part now to cover some
of these unique elements that we've
incorporated into the chemistry side the
we have the single primer extension
based enrichment and I wanted to to just
draw the you know draw some differences
between the traditional two primer
amplicon design that we currently see
with some approaches and the single
primer extension approach that we've
incorporated into our ties stick panels
including the chiastic tmb panel so you
see on the left hand side is the
traditional two primer amplicon design
where a specific region of interest
let's call it X 121 of EGFR is is
defined by 2 X 121 specific primers you
need a forward and a reverse primer that
flank exon 21 while this has been
extremely helpful for some applications
we know that this this type of approach
suffers from an increased risk of primer
dimers and dropouts there is a good
chance that some of these forward and
reverse primers will interact with each
other and drop out of the enrichment
step so you end up with you know a lack
of coverage across that across that
region we know because of the
these dropouts you have a lower type of
uniformity for you for your enrichment
and sequencing multiple pools or primers
might be required in order to separate
those primers in different pools to
maintain a specific amplicon size for
instance because the start and end
positions are very well-defined with
primers you end up with a low library
complexity and now increasing the panel
content might require primary design so
if you have a panel for instance today a
TMP panel of you know 300 genes and you
want to increase that number to 350 in
the next year you might have to redesign
the existing primers so in order to
overcome all of these challenges of a 2
primer amplicon design we've
incorporated single primer extension
approaches into our chiastic workflows
what the single primer extension means
single primer extension means that you
define your region of interest again
looking back at exon 21 of EGFR you're
defining your region of interest with
only one region specific primer however
this is still an amplicon based approach
the other primer on the other end is
going to be a primer that binds to
elements introduced in your library
construction steps so within the library
adapters we've incorporated sequencing
whereby this universal primer can can
bind to so now you have two two primers
to to you know to perform the enrichment
step however your region of interest is
only defined by one primer only the
advantages of such an approach is that
you end up with a lower risk of primer
dimers and dropouts and displease to a
higher degree of uniformity only a
single pool of primers is now required
instead of multiple pools of primers and
because you're only defining the start
position your stop position is going to
be completely random depending on where
that library that library adapter binds
to your your DNA molecules you end up
with a higher library complexity and
increasing the panel content now does
not require primary design because we we
have less primers and because the you're
only using a forward primer to define
your region increasing the panel content
does not require primary design of your
existing panel
now speaking about jumping to two unique
molecular indices and how they are
helpful when it comes to accurate
quantification of of transcripts and
also accurate calling of low frequency
variants and just kind of wanted to go
over this this unique element that we've
incorporated into our workflow as well
so why are unique molecular indices are
beneficial to your analysis well if
we're looking at only sort of the
quantification of transcripts if we're
looking at let's say gene expression
levels the top box shows you how you
know conventional targeted DNA or RNA
sequencing is done by looking at these
non unique reads right so if I'm trying
to quantify transcripts EGFR transcripts
and I'm using exon 21 for for this for
this type of quantification and if I end
up with these five reads that map back
to exon 21 of EGFR the challenge with
with just looking at these five
transcripts that look exactly like each
other is that I cannot tell whether I'm
looking at five unique DNA or RNA
molecules or I'm looking at quintuplets
of the same DNA or RNA molecule that was
just amplified over and over now this
becomes a challenge if you're trying to
achieve an accurate level of gene
expression analysis however if you
incorporate unique molecular indices
before any amplification takes place
into your your RNA or cDNA molecules
these um eyes are going to help you
distinguish between the two scenarios of
either unique DNA or RNA molecules or
quintuplets of the same DNA RNA molecule
and this is shown on the lower part of
the slide on the left hand side you see
five different unique molecules or
unique molecular indices that have been
in have been detected by the analysis
pipelines and because I have detected
five different um eyes I know that my my
starting material represents five
different five different transcripts of
EGFR because I am detecting five unique
molecular indices but if I only detect
one unique molecular index across all
five reads then most likely this has
just come from one transcript that was
amplified over and over so by by
analyzing data using using powerful
bioinformatics to
based on unique molecular indices and
not just raw reads I have a better and
more confident way of of analyzing gene
expression levels and the same can be
said for calling you know a variant
especially those that are present at low
frequencies within your sample if I'm
going to use exon 21 of EGFR as another
example if I if I have these five reads
that not back to exon twenty-one of EGFR
and I see an individual mutation and
just only one of these five reads
it is extremely difficult to distinguish
between these two scenarios a PCR or
sequencing error that was introduced you
know within within the workflow or
within sequencing or is this a true
low-frequency mutation by incorporating
unique molecular indices before any
amplification takes place I can build
more confidence in distinguishing
between these two different scenarios if
I see that mutation in only one of the
reads that carry the same unique
molecular index most likely this
mutation represents a false variant
because they say were they true variant
I should be able to see this specific
mutation in all of the reads that carry
the same inequality our index as you see
on the lower right hand side of this
slide
so a incorporating unique molecular
indices is going to allow me to build
more confidence in calling these kinds
of mutations so now going back to the
classic tmd panel I just wanted to kind
of go over
or just give you a sense of the content
of the coyote tmv panel it is a panel
that covers a wide range of relevant
biological processes as described here
I'm not going to go through all of these
biological processes but this is here
for for your reference
and at the same time it covers the
exonic regions of 486 genes again I'm
not going to go through every single one
of these genes but but they're listed
here for your reference and these genes
map back to those different biological
processes that I mentioned before and
this is this is my last my last slide
before I try and transition the the
presentation to to Dan just to go over
some specifications about the number of
genes in and other parameters for the
coyote TMD panel as I mentioned the
number of genes that are covered by the
by the coyote tmb panel is 486 genes the
number of primers required to do all of
the enrichment is 19,000 more than
19,000 primers and we can fit all of
these 19,000 primers in an individual
pool of primers which will generate only
one library per sample the number of
target bases which is also an important
metric to to look at when when it comes
to TMP analysis we cover 1.3 million
bases the types of variants that you can
call with with the coyote can be panel
you can you can generate a tmb score of
course a source you know this is
associated with the with the
bioinformatics pipelines that Karen has
built also for 40mb analysis you could
you could get tmb scores you could look
at snv's in those and copy number
variants as well some of the metrics
that we see coming out of the of the TMP
panel in terms of specificity which is
the percent of on target reads and
uniformity which is the percent of of
coverage around 20% of the mean coverage
in your in your sample we're seeing
specificity at about 95 percent and
uniformity at about 98% for for the TMB
panel recommended DNA input i mentioned
that the the chiastic workflow can
tolerate down to 10 nanograms of DNA but
for the TMV panel we recommend 40 nano
grams of DNA enrichment technology this
is single primer extension as I
mentioned before with unique molecular
indices the median applicant size is
about
seventy base pair so it's still
compatible with with with a fragmented
samples such as FFPE samples and sample
multiplexing levels you can multiplex up
to 384 samples on an Illumina platform
or up to 96 samples on an ion torrent
platform total work for time eight to
nine hours to go from an extracted DNA
sample all the way to libraries that can
be quantified and sequenced and a
variant allele frequency because we're
incorporating unique molecular indices
you can confidently call variants down
to 0.5 percent das
so with this I will turn it now to down
alright thanks right so what else talk
us through is a little bit about
pageants solution for interpretation of
variants including to mutation burden
but also a wide variety of somatic
cancer variants what we provide is
something called kaijin clinical insight
it's a universal solution in the sense
that it can take next-generation
sequencing data from any instrument
whether it's alumnos Ion Torrent
or the hyejin's gene reader sequencing
instrument and it supports a wide
variety of testing types including tumor
testing somatic cancer myeloid neoplasm
testing hereditary cancer carrier
screening among other germline tests as
well what it does is it takes the raw
data and you can put it through a
sequencing analysis pipeline of your
choice or we also provide something
called QC analyze it does the variant
alignment and calling for you
alternatively but that is fed into what
I'll talk today about it is QC I
interpret which provides the
interpretation of those somatic or
germline variants in the context of
current knowledge so that you can
produce a final report and in that
process it takes an O configuration for
each test you offer in your laboratory
it also takes patient metadata into
account and there's a means they'll talk
through later that allows you to
automate this to a large degree based on
your labs standard operating procedures
to get to that final report
so let's start with some of the
challenges of interpretation so when
you're interpreting a somatic alteration
found in a tumor there's a couple of
different considerations one is
pathogenicity which may affect
prognostic significance of their aunt or
how for example how aggressive the tumor
may be there's also clinical relevance
or actionability as we call it which is
what you can do based on the molecular
evidence to help the patient in terms of
therapeutic options of gnostic
significance diagnostic significance and
some myeloid cancers for example
so both assessing the pathogenicity the
ability of the alteration to drive a
tumor progression as well as action
ability what treatment options are
available to patient based on the
particular bomb markers they have have a
variety of different considerations that
have to be taken account to assess the
pathogenicity or action ability so for
example a lot of this is based on
literature in terms of what's been
established in the scientific and
clinical literature about the role of
various alterations and driving tumor
progressions such as functional studies
or recurrence of particular mutations
and particular tumor types there's a
wide variety of other databases as well
in terms of providing frequencies of
tumors or clinical page reports or
predictions of their effect on function
on the actionability side there's a
constant of drug approvals updated
guideline recommendations multiple times
a year for different cancer types
there's constantly changing clinical
trial availability in terms of opening
closing trials and always new study
publications so keeping up with all this
is a challenge so to you know put it
more concretely on on average each month
there's one to three new drug approvals
or label extensions for targeted
therapies there's about 250 new clinical
trials for target therapies that open in
140 that stop recruiting
and there's a constantly growing
year-over-year number of literature of
publications on tumor variance in their
response to drugs and so it is a chart
at the bottom to shows the total
publications per year as a proxy for
each each year for somatic cancer
mutations and drug context so what does
this mean for the lab a bunch of
challenges to do this type of tau so you
need consistent and reproducible
interpretation across your clinical
staff you need access to most current
information for action ability to make
an informative report for your physician
customers you need a visibility of
underlying evidence to support the
treatment options you now understand why
the system is providing some particular
options for the patient and this has to
be done in a simple way with a fast
turnaround time so you can return your
tests quickly if you're ordering
physicians and it needs to be aligned
with the guidelines to both amp and ACMG
have come out with guidelines from
recent years in terms of how to view
passages see how to view action ability
so briefly of pathogenicity is
categorized into one of five categories
in terms of the variants ability to
drive disease progression ranging from
pathogenic down to benign for AC amps
guidelines there's a peering mechanism
for actionability in terms of whether
there's strong clinical evidence that a
treatment prognostic or diagnostic
significant exists for an alteration
down to unknown clinical significance
and benign status and that they have
guideline recommendations for how to
report out these variants based on these
categories
as a touchdown Cajuns solution is Kaizen
clinical insight for the interpretation
reporting of alterations for precision
medicine what I'll focus on in this talk
is Kaizen clinical insight support for
oncology or somatic alterations there's
many many labs use it for hereditary
disease as well including hereditary
cancer which is also emerging many
molecular pathology labs as a testing
occasion so what is Kaizen clinical
insight first thing it's evidence-based
software so it's a web application and
you can provide your alterations that
you detect off your pipeline to along
with metadata for the case and it
assists in the classification reporting
of alterations from any next generation
sequencing platform it provides
comprehensive annotation and literature
evidence so that provides the
information about why of particular
variants pathogenic for example it
provides a fast automated decision
support so applies the standard
guidelines and there's each of those
guidelines has many different criteria
for establishing the level or tier of
pathogenicity or actionability it
computes those as all we cover a little
more deeply in a moment here but it
provides you the current most accurate
computed evidence available for any
alteration that you detect it also
provides the treatment and trial
identification the options for somatic
reporting for a particular patient based
on what trials are currently available
and relevant for their particular marker
and demographic such as their age and
gender and stage of the tumor and last
it provides customized reporting so
there you can use kaijin clinical
insight both via API only if you choose
but many labs use it to produce their
final time clinical reports - so we have
customized reporting capability as well
and tool to streamline the workflow I
want to take a few minutes to talk about
titans knowledge base in our unique and
innovative way of curating
into clinical evidence so first it
starts with us finding acquiring
purchasing prioritizing organizing
indexing the clinical literature that is
relevant for particular genes or disease
areas we have over 100 expert curators
PhDs and MDS that go through the primary
literature guidelines drug labels and
other sources and extract the primary
evidence from them so this is really
importantly we got gather the primary
evidence from these sources in put it
into the knowledge base in a computable
format and what that means is it's not
just people writing arbitrary sentences
but it's structured so that sentences
can produce like the one at the bottom
here but they're computed over by the
Kaizen clinical insight software among
other capabilities we provide that
leverage this structured knowledge and
that enables the knowledgebase then to
provide a sort of a current means of
getting a up-to-date assessment computed
for any bearing or alteration in any
disease context at any time based on all
this structured knowledge contained in
the knowledge base that is drived
directly from primary evidence published
in the literature and so rather than
having to sort of curate one variant at
a time and go back and reiterate and
reiterate we curate the evidence
directly and have the computer do that
synthesis based on the guideline
requirements automatically at any point
in time so it's a much more efficient
and comprehensive means of getting an
assessment of alterations in their
clinical significance and past unity so
give you a sense of some slices of
information in the knowledge base for
example there's over 13,000 manually
curated alteration drug response disease
associations and a wide variety of
cancer types
a lot of lung cancer colorectal cancer
melanoma for example across hundreds
hundreds of genes and hundred over 100
indications likewise for clinical trials
we curate the current clinical trials
which are get updated
weakly in to both biomarker required
trials and would require certain
biomarkers for eligibility or in some
cases exclude patients based on presence
of certain biomarkers we also curate
biomarker relevant trials and so this
leverages knowledge of the direct
protein and in some cases variant
targets of drugs in trials to match
patients to trials where there may be a
response based on knowledge of the drug
even if the trial does not explicitly
have biomarker requirements in terms of
eligibility criteria stated and so this
covers hundreds of genes and many
hundreds of cancer indications another
slice is prognostic evidence so this
over close to 3,000 manually curated
prognostic outcome disease associations
and a wide variety of cancers
particularly for our human to logical or
myeloid malignancy testing there can be
a lot of prognostic significance in
terms of particular alterations detected
so we provide that content in cash in
clinical insight to and so there's this
constant change of literature guidance
documents for particular cancer types
and drug labels and so we're constantly
curating that 24/7 and update the
product hygiene clinical insight
essentially weekly for clinical trials
FDA EMA drug labels primary literature
and guidelines for men NCCN is used by
many but since hygiene clinical insight
is available in many geographies
worldwide we also support European
guidelines like asthma for example among
others as well so to take a quick look
at how the software looks once you
provide either through the API or
through a web interface to upload a VCF
file the variants that you detect from a
tumor along with the patient demographic
information that's used for for example
clinical trial matching based on age
gender and stage of their tumor you see
is sort of the automatically classified
status of the particular alterations in
that to
learn from in terms of biological
pathogenicity as well as a tier 1 to
tier 4 actionability in terms of
therapeutic or prognostic significance
for example so you can click on any
Garen to get a deeper view of the
supporting evidence and so what this is
showing is the amp categories supporting
the pathogenesis actionability of this
particular tumor a variant in this
particular tumor type in terms of the
biomarker predicts response to
fda-approved therapy for the specific
diagnosis in this case a non small cell
lung cancer cases what we're looking at
here but there's many other lines of
evidence that in the amp guidelines are
also supporting the overall tier 1 a
criteria you can click on the LA I info
icon on the tile to also see more detail
on terms the pathogenicity of the
variant in terms of how it drives tumor
progression and there's a wide variety
of different biological criteria that
are met there's about 30 or so different
criteria in the pathogenicity guidelines
for assessment in that sense and so
those are all dynamically computed based
on the latest available clinical
evidence has been curated into knowledge
base you can click on any particular
line of criteria line of evidence to see
the supporting literature and go into
the literature if you so choose you can
also see the system-generated sentence
that we call in findings that it's a
primary evidence from that article that
was curated that supports that
particular criteria and while the system
provides you an overall up-to-date a
computed classification you can set your
assessment and you need to set this up
either through policy or through using
the user interface manually in terms of
deciding what you want to report out for
the particular variant so you can set
the pathogenicity you can set the action
ability whether it goes into your report
or not for example at
an override what the computer comes up
with but the computers trying to support
you in the decision and making a
streamlined and accurate comprehensive
as possible
likewise for the drug therapies they're
categorized based on action building in
the particular cancer type in so
relative to non small cell lung cancer
there's certain evidence that some of
the this particular biomarker confers a
lack of response to certain drugs as
well as is on indication or on label for
other drugs like this emergent if in
this case once you're done either having
your clinical staff review the case and
do an initial workup or applying a
policy which I'll talk about in a moment
here to streamline and automate that
triage you the lab director typically
comes into a page that lists for each
case the variants that would be reported
out along with the treatments and trials
so you can adjust prior to finalizing
the report there's also interpretive
comments for drugs and for alterations
that sort of explain the biological
significance so you can edit or reuse
from others and the process involves
either a review by staff or a sign out
directly by the lab director who can
then go to this page for each case and
just click a sign out to electronically
sign and finalize report if they so
choose the report produced by the system
can be very readily customized but in
general the first page highlights
actionable alterations and associated
therapies it distinguishes the
[Music]
alterations that confer sensitivity to
drugs from those that confer Lac
response or resistance to particular
appease in subsequent pages generally
have the variant specific interpretive
comments the specific clinical trials
available and what drug for which
biomarker and where they're located we
can locate there's a variety can target
clinical trials for your patient
population and your particular Institute
as well
and so overall you know once you have
that final report you're able to provide
that interpretation reporting for your
particular panel or test that reporting
I should mention also supports TM be a
notion of tumour mutation burden that
right talked about earlier can also be
included as part of the report if your
pipeline your panel determines TM be
score for example and what I want uh cha
now is yeah the types of clinical
interpret has been around for many years
now we've had many many hundreds of
thousands of samples interpreted with it
and this is slightly dated number there
many earlier on many labs did their own
super manual comparison of how they
scored interpreted variants road to the
computed approach that Kaizen clinical
insight provides fine found very high
concordance as well as a great reduction
in time for case because essentially
cousin at clinical and say once you
establish that it interprets the
variance they're looking for in the
particular genes you test for
dramatically reduces the time you need
to spend searching for information to be
confident in that you're considering all
the relevant treatment trials clinical
evidence and practice guidelines that
sort of all readily at hand for you and
use to streamline that interpretation
process so overall to science were
printed scalable standardized
reproducible and next-generation
sequencing interpretation and recording
solution you can using a lab a couple
other things I want to touch on to
highlight is you can review historic
assessments in your labs variant
database since you these cases go can be
an idea identified into the cloud to be
interpreted or identified based on
whatever your lab so chooses you can
search for all variants that you've seen
before in Prior cases either update
those cases review those cases as well
as seen for example in which cancer
types you've seen a particular
alteration previously if you if you want
to take a look it has a
director in terms of occurrences of
covariance in your lab it's also
available via API integration so some
some of our customers would do a
straight API integration and use their
own tools to do the final review and
sign out but if you so choose you can
use the inner user interface that you
show it as well so you could sort of do
that interactive reviewing and deeper
dive into the evidence as well and then
it's QC automates the reporting through
policies I want to close on just
touching on what that means
so there's interpretation reporting
policies and then on top right there as
part of a test product configuration so
once you've defined your panel it's
whatever however many genes you're
testing your testing tumors for examples
for somatic cancer indication it's
produced variant calls or alteration
calls for seeing these fusions and
mutations for example that is fed into
QC I interpret with your test product
configuration and the patient metadata
the interpretation policy enables your
laboratory to define how that the levels
of evidence that need to be met to
improve up to include certain evidence
on the report the final report so what
we've recently done is provide an amp
guidelines line to automated variant
reporting policy they can review and
incorporate into your standard operating
procedure if you sort of choose which
enables the system to automatically
triage the variants for you and produce
a draft final report from which you can
then review in that lab report and
directors page and adjust if you see fit
or finalize and so I won't go into
detail here but it basically defines
based on the amperes which variance
should go on the report and in what
sections it defines what level evidence
should be met to report a treatment for
particular alteration on the report and
how to match clinical trials based on
the patient demographics when they're
available in other criteria in terms of
specific eligibility or ineligibility
criteria so with that I'm going to close
and I just say that to interpret
standardizes NGS interpretation
reporting it automates the guidelines so
provide the scales with standardized and
reproducible interpretation reporting
solution for you that produces
actionable clinical reports with full
transparency to the supporting clinical
evidence so you can answer any questions
or address any questions you have either
from your customers or from internal
considerations to finalize a report with
confidence and so Q Center provides
standardized clinical decision support
and reporting for any sequencing assay
pipeline or platform so thank you for
your attention
and now I'll progress to our Q&A period
thank you doctor smart and dr. Richards
for that informative presentation we
will now start the Q&A portion of the
webinar and we'll address some of the
most commonly asked questions by our
viewers if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button our speakers
will follow up with your questions via
email so let's get started our first
question is is going to be for dr.
Richards in the process of curating
variant data how does your platform
resolve conflicting evidence and are we
as ones that sign off on the report able
to review this information prior to
signing off
yes that's a great question so the
literature is constantly changing and
emerging markers for example are
identified over time through a
succession of clinical studies often
then establish their clinical
actionability and likewise for
pathogenicity there's a wide variety of
functional studies among other types of
evidence and establish pathogenicity and
so that they is loading - yeah the
classifications do change over time
particularly for variants that are of
uncertain significance as more evidence
gets published when a case is cases
change the system will automatically
produce the current computed
classification based on the current
available evidence so when you go into
the system you'll always see the most
recent data because it's dynamically
computed rather than somebody manually
reviewing the evidence case-by-case and
the subject - one person's manual
judgment since the all the
classifications are based on the
guidelines and that framework and using
the computable evidence we curated a
knowledge base it provides a current
view of what is known about each variant
and you can view that at any time
now dr. Samara what level concordance do
you see between data from your TFT panel
and exome data
right so traditionally tmb analysis has
been done using exome data in the
initial reports that reported out on on
you know the benefit of TMD analysis for
immunity and you know therapies have
used the you know an excellent analysis
however we've we recognize that exome
level of analysis is not going to be
financially sustainable it it does take
a lot of sequencing capacity to produce
tmb scores off of exomes so the next
question was well if we cannot use exome
you know in a you know in a sustainable
manner what kind of content do we go
after you know that we represent sort of
an excellent type of analysis and so
what researchers have found is that a
content that is anywhere between 300 to
500 genes representing you know a
million to two million bases of sequence
is good enough and it would produce a
high level of concordance between you
know that panel level of analysis and an
exome level analysis when we look at how
our tmb panel compares to an exome level
analysis we do see a high degree of
concordance in the sense that those
samples that get classified as tmb high
with with an excellent level of analysis
will also show as tmb high with it with
our TMP panel so we do we do see a high
level of concordance between exome type
of data and the chiastic tmv panel
dr. Richard says new information emerges
that impact existing variant
classification does your platform alert
you to previously closed reports that
may require re-examination it can so
many of our customers they do that
primarily for a writer cancer not for
somatic cancer because in the patient's
clinical journey for somatic cancer a
tumor can change rather rapidly so there
is less of a heard last request to go
back to re previous somatic cancer
reports and update them but for Grad ter
cancer that's certainly the case and we
provide two means to address that need
one is in the user interface if your
customer calls you and would like
updated assessment of a grant report
that you've issued previously you can
find our report and hydrogen clinical
insight and see that as that leads to
the most recent classification based on
currently available evidence and so that
sometimes happens for variants of
uncertain significance for example if a
year or two later your customer
physician may want to see if there's any
new evidence on that for their patient
and that's very easy to sort of just
look up directly through the variant
database so to speak that hygen clinical
insight provides for larger laboratories
reference laboratories on a maybe
quarterly basis they typically is
application programming API integration
with kaijin clinical insight to see if
there's new literature available for any
of the variants that are in that
category of us variants of uncertain
significance for example and that
likewise can be used to determine
whether certain cases get reviewed by
laboratory staff to issue a unamended
reporter update report at their
discretion and that's more rather than
on-demand that's sort of typically done
quarterly or whenever that may wish to
periodically review such older reports
to proactively update their customers
now our next question is for dr. Samara
can you call fusions with your TOB panel
so a short answer is with with the DNA
the cacique tmv panel that I just
described we cannot call fusions off of
RNA however what we've recognized is
that the necessity to call fusions
you know alongside TM b TM b or 40 mb
analysis is not it's not necessary
because TM b analysis is all about the
types or the number of mutations that
that are detected within a sample
however having said so a lot of
researchers are also looking at gene
expression levels and fusion analysis
you know as a as a more comprehensive
approach to to accomplish that omics
type of approach for for immuno oncology
analysis so what what one can do with
our TM b panel is to combine it with a
with another panel that utilizes RNA as
a starting material construct libraries
off of the RNA and enrich for specific
fusions or enrich for even just one you
know one partner of the of the different
fusions that can be detected within a
sample so you could use a another panel
that starts off with RNA as starting
material construct your libraries and
then combine the libraries from your RNA
starting material alongside the the
libraries from the TM be the KIC TM b
panel put them all onto one sequencing
flow cell and in in sequence your DNA
and RNA libraries so again short answer
is as it stands alone it cannot but it
can be combined with another panel that
looks like fusions
and it looks like we have time for one
more question so we'll switch back over
to you dr. Richards there are a few
similar solutions in the market that
leverage artificial intelligence how is
your platform different and what makes
it better than solely a I driven
platforms yeah so Titans been developing
this knowledgebase to manual creation
and modeling of the knowledge sure for
over 20 years so the alternative
approach artificial intelligence
approach looks for patterns or recurrent
patterns and that tries to guide
decision making but cancer carriers
complexes in this evidence base is
constantly changing and so those
patterns just like the guidelines can
change quarterly and that to do an
accurate job of interpreting the
variance and determine the current
clinical significance really requires a
clear and accurate modeling or
interpretation of the current of
clinical evidence which is a challenge
for AI driven systems since they're
unless you have somebody actually
reading and encoding the information
they always have issues with missing
details or missing contextual
information and not necessarily getting
all the relevant literature for
particular alteration due to that for
example the many different names for
genes and different nomenclatures used
for different mutations for example that
makes it a challenge as well as even
things like as simple as diagnosis
there's not a standardized vocabulary
for molecular pathology diagnosis of
cancer so you know we get non small cell
lung cancer along adenocarcinoma and
those types of things where unless a
system that day I driven gains a lot of
human expert knowledge it's not going to
automatically figure out those are the
very similar and how to treat them in a
appropriate way so Kaizen through our
knowledge base we have PhD MD scientists
that work on modeling that knowledge for
associating things together in a way
that enables them to be computed over
accurately and also making sure that all
the relevant evidence at any point in
time in the right concept context is
manual
curated we found no substitute to doing
that for accuracy and interpretation and
so that's the the key thing is really it
can't be doing it manually in terms
accuracy and getting comprehensive
evidence we do use AI to help identify
articles that our curators go after but
we found that sort of as good as it gets
currently with the latest artificial
intelligence in terms of doing a
value-added identification of evidence
to curate
to once again thank dr. Samara and dr.
Richards for their presentation I would
also like to thank Ivan for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through February
of 2019 you will receive an email from
laboratory you know when this webcast
will be available for replay play shows
an announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now thank you for joining us and we
hope to see you again soon
goodbye